look at my [ __ ] shirt oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
jujitsu tomorrow I'm good hey what's
going on everybody so first we feast I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings today I'm joined by
Joey cocoa Diaz you can catch him on the
silver screen you can catch him on the
stand-up stage and on his podcast the
Church of what's happening now Joey
welcome to the show thank you for having
my brother how are you with hot food
whatever you know
I'll [ __ ] try I'm a little
disappointed in myself because we didn't
bring you bleu cheese today I should
have brought bleu cheese did you oh no
you know when it comes to the world is
[ __ ] amateurs you got to do it
yourself but this is as good as bleu
cheese as a [ __ ] to get okay
with the chunks in it and pubic hair
this is good [ __ ] ready you're ready to
go and to all you we're all trying do
whatever the [ __ ] you wanna do
[Music]
so they were already on that mm-hmm
I was [ __ ] comedy seems to oftentimes
come out of adversity you know Chris
Rock and even bullied on the playground
and your origin story is like that times
a hundred as I understand it you sort of
honed your craft in prison when the
jail's projector system went down you'd
go up there and do impromptu stand-up
sets the projector broke and they were
like looking around like Restless before
they start to lawn chairs or something
and that went on for a few weeks and
then they would just go cue but go up
there and I would go up there and say
stupid stuff and I didn't even know I
was working on stand up I was just
trying to kill time do you miss it no
way do I miss it kinda sometimes it was
a different experience it was like
summer camp as an adult you know no
curfew
some people had jobs where the Italian
got it cooked and then people got stuff
from visitation like Mexican dudes got
tacos too sales right white dude's got
meth you know everybody got something
good everyone has done wrong so Monday
is they used to be this biker that I
became friends with and his girlfriend
which smuggled methane and I'd do a
little wine with him even though I
didn't do it I don't give a [ __ ]
important and we go play basketball it's
like having a heart attack it's like any
one of these [ __ ] wings try to run
around on meth and [ __ ] so I don't even
know what the [ __ ] question was this
thing so hot I love it so this one is
Tabasco I want to talk to you about
Easter morning because last night I got
on the phone with one of our mutual
friends and I'm talking about the
Machine Bert Kreischer who told me that
at Easter morning you brought weed
popcorn over for Bert's dad that's true
and what just happened like a little
party he was in this man cave and you
know like when you're mingling with
people and [ __ ] I was just passing the
popcorn around hoping that Bert's father
would taking a neat you know and mingle
and sure enough he got he thought it was
like he thought he was out of [ __ ]
for me he's eating popcorn like hahahaha
I love that type of [ __ ] I don't like
dosing you what like poison to something
but I like toasting it a little bit of
THC just so you know what the [ __ ] you
stand and he told me Burt that he ended
up having a very deep heavy conversation
with his dad
the on weed popcorn that he says changed
his life and brought him and his dad
closer together
that's an amazing concept and I did it
without know it I didn't do it cuz I'm
no [ __ ] psychological genius I just
did it cuz I wanna think I'm his dad
[ __ ] up when I go into a weed still I
want to see the devil mm-hmm that's why
I don't shop in Hollywood on Melrose
because they're all too [ __ ] nice
Gentiles you can't say that word in
there I want to see the [ __ ] devil if
I want to Flav I got a lifesaver
I'm saying no pineapple what the [ __ ]
are you talking about you know I want to
get down [ __ ]
[Music]
let me feel definitely blessing beers
that's on you that's on you that's my
[ __ ] the time Joey that's my [ __ ]
so I don't need to check your Wikipedia
page to know that you grew up in New
Jersey it's very much in the way you
walk it's very much in the way you talk
it's very much in the stand-up so what I
want to do is show you some pop cultural
byproducts of New Jersey and just get
your snap reactions to them okay I want
to know what you think all right laptop
please very high budget here Joey who
gives a [ __ ] about the budget when you
got heart The Sopranos three you
Sopranos guy yes sir it's his home in
fact it's crazy I'm gonna say this I
looked at my wife about four days ago
when I said James Gandolfini's probably
the first actor that's ever died that I
actually missed and I never met him how
about this one then it's a different
totally different show the Jersey Shore
uh I can't tell you I hate them 30 years
ago I didn't have the greased up and the
six-pack but that was me I was going to
the Jersey Shore eating [ __ ] gorilla
biscuits and quaaludes and going to
[ __ ] Montego Bay sad this club down
the shore Montego Bay and then the happy
hour was uh Alabama Slama sand kamikazes
they used to call them Red Devils with
two or three quaaludes
you gotta bother understanding it was
over Chris Christie oh he gets on my
last [ __ ] nerves he's just gonna
waste a [ __ ] life [ __ ] him what about
the bond [ __ ] Taylor ham and
[ __ ] egg Taylor him as good as
it gets
that's your life in the morning I don't
know that by the balance [ __ ]
breakfast I was growing up in Jersey was
a tail ham and egg and a 16-ounce
coconut can or are you who there's your
guy Frank Sinatra slung more dick in
Hollywood than any [ __ ] ever did
it his way you know the other day I was
on my friends podcast and I was talking
about my influences my stand-up is
Richard Pryor it's it's it's Julius
Erving it's an odd choice it's the
[ __ ] Allman Brothers I like wiped out
and
[ __ ] I'm gonna get down you know the
Allman Brothers was white brilliance you
know and that's interesting to that
raaagh on other crafts as influences
absolutely absolutely that's who I am
I'm a dirty [ __ ] Cuban redneck so
this is Queen Majesty there's actually
coffee in this one so I want to talk
about bars because it seems like you're
kind of raised in bars and I know that
your mother owned a bar when you were on
that scene and say the 80s where was the
crazier more dangerous bar scene was it
in New Jersey or was it across the river
in Manhattan well I grew up in that age
but I was never really a big club guy I
got was never a VIP guy and session B
with bottles I don't know nothing about
that [ __ ] world but to answer your
question uh New York City it was crazy
in those days especially for me I hung
out with some crazy [ __ ] we mugged a
hooker lots of stories archive dot all
my god felony ones good ones funny ones
sad ones are you ready to move on [ __ ]
you not bad mile maybe has a little
afterburner I'm not sure you on this
[ __ ] blood tomorrow you know when I was
forty and thirty you could eat anything
now I eat so pepperoni another [ __ ]
eight times the next day I'm gonna be an
issue I'll [ __ ] it I don't give a [ __ ] I
won't go to jujitsu tomorrow cuz you
don't want your [ __ ] to sweat that's
a perfect segue because I want to talk
to you about jujitsu and before I start
first congratulations on the blue belt
thank you and I know that you're good
friends with Joe Rogan that just first
trip to the dojo is that his influence
or is that something that you did on
your own I did on my own can you talk to
me about what influenced you to do that
I was too embarrassed to tell anybody
then a couple years ago I got up to four
hundred eighteen pounds I know I had to
do something so I went to the Y like off
hours so nobody would see me [ __ ] I'm
working out and [ __ ] but then I move to
the valley so I joined the kickboxing
school
and UFC has really kicked in and I'm
getting all these [ __ ] kids that
grease their hair and do steroids in
this kick the [ __ ] out of me and I go
you find a no I'm a fireman why you
[ __ ] me up like this and I went home
and I'm like what am i a [ __ ] you know
what if I'm with my daughter and
somebody jumps me and I'm on the floor
and I can't [ __ ] breathe no I'm going
back so for six months I went back I
didn't tell nobody that was terrible
listen man I'm still [ __ ] terrible
but guess what
I was terrible when I was doing comedy
five years it's just something you have
to hang in what just keep showing up you
know you're gonna get beat up they're
gonna tell you no but at the end you let
a [ __ ] have something that nobody
else has you're gonna have the
experience and it's interesting that you
talk about it that way because you're
talking about how it sucks it's the
worst it's this it's that but it seems
like it's very much a part of you now oh
I can't your love it's lovely I don't do
my agents here
you don't call me Monday Wednesday and
Fridays when I'm in town I won't do it
twelve to one I gotta go I gotta go you
have to go I get away from all this [ __ ]
this gets on your nerves after a while
you know like what time is your spot to
write this that you got to write a joke
podcast you just want to go somewhere
where you want to be a fat [ __ ] we sit
in the back of the class you see me
sweating now this is nothing commanded I
sit in the back huffin and puffin my
suit don't fit my [ __ ] pants fall off
but I keep [ __ ] going and that's it
if you were put in a position to defend
yourself what would come out would it be
the jujitsu training or would it be the
Jersey and yet the gun [ __ ] I'm 53 I
got time to hand and wrestle
I got a 22 in my ass all right now
pointing straight at you
this one has blueberry in it and ghost
pepper let's try it let's try it out
you became a father at 50 years old yes
and there are a lot of insane parenting
trends going on in 2017 I'm sizing you
up you don't look like the type to
coddle your child but you know what
you're a famous comedian you make a
couple bucks what do you think of
requiring nannies to have master's
degrees that's a big thing that's close
enough
I live in the [ __ ] Valley Village up
there with those [ __ ] months okay
I love swimming I'm CUBAN it's in my
[ __ ] blood so I take my kid to the Y
to a swimming class and I would go in
there with him my wife both of us you
know many [ __ ] times I saw a nanny in
the pool while the two [ __ ] parents
were sitting there on the [ __ ] phones
okay right raising the kids when your
kids sucking dick or jumping up and down
on Santa Monica it's on you it's on
[ __ ] you okay it's on [ __ ] you
when he's doing drugs and he's all
[ __ ] up but whatever the [ __ ] he's
doing cuz he didn't have the decency to
jump in the [ __ ] pool I have a woman
who comes into my house twice but she's
pretty much comes in to clean and help
out she watches mercy for an hour here
but I don't wanna know nanny raising my
[ __ ] kid
for this one zombie apocalypse oh Jesus
[Music]
now this is pretty hot you feel it
got some Wang to it I want to talk about
Joe Rogan for a second because he's
called you the funniest man alive and I
know that you make frequent appearances
on his podcast there's a lot of
cross-pollination he's a dear friend you
know I've learned a lot about standing
from him you know he's the Rodney
Dangerfield of our era because Rodney
really launched the careers of dice
Kennison Hicks when he did those young
comedian vessels so Rogen's pretty much
this [ __ ] turn on the heat them
right now yeah he was sucked at my
titties the first six wings what role if
any do you think he's played in helping
you reach a new younger audience he's
played a tremendous role he's very
generous
he's my mom died when I was 16 he's
bought me more stakes than my mom could
ever buy me I'm very lucky to have him
and Arion Duncan and red banner we live
and breathe for one of them and that's
very rare in the comedy business snots
are coming out of my nose uncontrollably
thank God I got a bidet cuz my balls are
sweating right now you have a bidet
oh [ __ ] your portable but then you gotta
get one dawg do you have like a remote
do you have different settings how does
always sit there press the button let
the cold water hit you [ __ ] that's it
the bangs you little scrotum and wait to
the hot water hits it that's a complete
different one that's when you just tell
the girlfriend your services are not
needed no more I do my own arms yeah I
got something to spit in my [ __ ]
nobody does that oh cool hidden jesus
[ __ ] christ that is a real deal might
be it for Joey Diaz I don't want to know
what Joey Diaz is it true that when you
came to the United States you were
attacked by dogs over and over again for
some reason I just had a bad look I kept
getting bit like dogs
my dogs is this in New Jersey or where
is this is walking the Bronx at my
mother's dry cleaner then I got bit on
148th Street in the leg then I got a bit
of Catholic school how do you support
issues
I got brain matter coming up I even got
an old [ __ ] rock that came out it was
stuck against the [ __ ] wall
[Music]
that is [ __ ] hijacked my wife told me
to bring bread I shouldn't listen you
should have you did bring blue cheese
and weed we like to smoke the joint in
here we got pulled into the I got pulled
into the principal's office the other
week whoo we get in trouble Natalie
cover for us don't snitch on us now we
cut the shirts 2017
you lucky I don't have a lighter
[Music]
so this one is Mad Dog 357 357 thousand
Scoville units it is a very intensely
hot hot sauce as you know from have
trying this one and trying this one now
this one and the one more that we have
look at my [ __ ] shirt
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] jujitsu tomorrow I'm
good looks like God Patrick Ewing at the
free-for-all [ __ ] I know that your
cocaine cowboy days are over but anyone
who watches you on periscope knows that
you're still very much a weed guy when
you smoke are you a couch lock guy or
you take a walk guy what are you doing
[ __ ] out of house a move let me get
another napkin I'm on fire like Madonna
look at this [ __ ] have you got any uh
bad edibles experiences have you ever
pushed it to the limit have you ever
gone to oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah I had a
meeting once and I ate some banana bread
that was killing [ __ ] and I
hate to pieces and I was sweating more
than I am now I had to take my shirt off
on my suit and drive home with the
windows open in the air on I was so high
I couldn't make a right turn
that's when you know you [ __ ] up whoo
that's the real [ __ ] deal my friend
still in some milk take it off
[Music]
we don't [ __ ] with milk nah don't like
it I'll drink a milkshake like right now
I'd go for 18 [ __ ] milkshakes
this is Blair's Megadeth sauce with
liquid rage
it has tradition around here to put a
little dab on the last oh [ __ ] that you
don't have to if you don't want to Joey
I'm dead I'm tapping Joey that's all
good
don't dad don't damn if you're gonna
walk on ice you might as well pinch you
don't say I love it I love it very hot
hot sauce doctor guys push it out get
that one that's the one that killed
[ __ ] Kennedy when Kennedy got shot
for this shoot him with a bullet it's
[ __ ] hot sauce as far as motivational
comedians go I think that there's you
and I think that there's Kevin Hart and
then there's everybody else he's a
little more reach for the stars you're a
little more grab it by the balls so
while we're kind of dying on this last
Hot Sauce I think it would be great if
you could tell the hot ones fans out
there you know give them some sort of
motivational speech so that they can get
through their week while you're dying on
hot sauce
who the [ __ ] would listen to me with
this shirt on red in the face with my
[ __ ] fungi toenail fungus spreading
through my head right now is that my
toenails hurt right now that's not
cannot sauce made my fungi now excuse me
brolo let him tell you dick don't let
them tell you dick go for it [ __ ]
I want people to know that you could do
what oh the [ __ ] you want no matter
what's happened but I was sleeping on a
[ __ ] a rocket ship out of park he
understand me jerking off
snorting call waking up with kids
yelling around me and I go and drink
water and that was my [ __ ] day in
1984 okay it was 30 years ago whatever
but I was still in that position man I
still know what it feels like to wake up
with [ __ ] three inches from your face
and [ __ ] but look at you now you cleared
the board 10 wings showed up none of
them are left you made it through Joey
this camera that camera that camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life I got dick going out right
now I got a specialist see so TV go to
see so impressing Joey and get it for
free all right I got week's coming
although we'll go to Joey Diaz net to
see when I come to your hometown thank
you for having me [ __ ] then feel
it in the back of my throat hey what's
going on hot ones fans if you liked the
video maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you liked
the video subscribe thank you very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend